[Aplausos]
[Música]
el presidente de eeuu donald trump lo
tiene claro claro meridiano no va a
desistir continúa adelante con su empeño
de desatar su particular guerra mundial
en este caso toda una guerra comercial
contra el resto del mundo
sí
y has convencido de que los eeuu están
siendo perjudicados e incluso robados en
sus relaciones comerciales en los
últimos meses donald trump ha puesto en
marcha una dura política proteccionista
y ha multiplicado los aranceles
desde ahora miles y miles de millones de
dólares en productos importados por eeuu
tendrán que hacer frente a los fuertes
aranceles aprobados por esta
administración
ya sabes compra productos
estadounidenses si no es que no eres un
auténtico patriota bienvenidos a 1930
pues bien el caso es que durante este
mes de julio de 2018 comenzaron a
aplicarse aranceles ni más ni menos que
del 25 por ciento sobre productos que
eeuu importa cada año de china por valor
de 50 mil millones de dólares además
apenas unos meses antes la casa blanca
puso en marcha aranceles contra las
importaciones de acero aluminio placas
solares e incluso lavadoras
pero por supuesto no penséis que aquí
termina todo para nada tran ya tiene
sobre la mesa planes para poner en
marcha próximamente muchos más aranceles
has jugado alguna vez al monopoly o al
risk pues digamos que a ojos del
presidente norteamericano todo este
asunto es algo así como un juego de mesa
y amigos no está dispuesto a perder
[Música]
ahora bien va realmente a resultar tan
sencillo se cumplirá el plan del
presidente norteamericano y la economía
se fortalecerá con este tipo de
políticas estas son las preguntas clave
de momento lo que ya sabemos es que el
discurso de donald trump está empezando
a crear muchos pero que muchos nervios
en las multinacionales norteamericanas
no creo que esto vaya a resolverse
fácilmente y creo que estos aranceles
van a perjudicar a la economía
norteamericana
rufus y ex presidente del consejo
nacional de comercio exterior que
representa a multinacionales como
coca-cola ford y microsoft y es que
lejos de lo prometido las primeras
víctimas están siendo norteamericanas
atentos
[Música]
el sueño roto en la casa blanca lo
repiten una y otra vez esta nueva
política tiene como objetivo impulsar a
las empresas estadounidenses sin embargo
antes de que los partidarios de trump
lancen las campanas al vuelo' esperar un
momento porque hay algunas cosas que el
presidente no cuenta
la primera es que la inmensa mayor parte
de los aranceles se están aplicando
sobre bienes intermedios y de capital
esto es los bienes que las empresas
importan para fabricar sus productos en
los eeuu de tal forma que una de dos o
pagan en arancel o empiezan a comprar en
otros mercados incluso suponiendo que
sea posible en los propios eeuu
en cualquier caso eso supone un mayor
coste de producción lo que evidentemente
reduce la competitividad de las empresas
del país
este es por ejemplo el caso de mit
continent neil una empresa de missouri
que es la mayor productora de clavos de
eeuu y que tras los aranceles aprobados
por trump al acero extranjero ha tenido
que despedir ya a 60 de sus 500
empleados y todo apunta a que podría
verse obligada a cerrar o trasladar toda
su producción a méxico una empresa que
funcionaba que creaba empleo que era
competitiva en un mercado libre y que
ahora por la intromisión de washington
se está viniendo abajo luego la segunda
cuestión seguro que nos sorprende es que
el resto de países no se están quedando
quietos para defender los intereses
centrales del país y los intereses del
pueblo nos vemos obligados a tomar
represalias declaración del ministerio
de comercio de china ojo por ojo
europa responde con más aranceles a la
guerra comercial de donald trump que tú
me pones un arancel pues yo te pongo
otro y así suma y sigue no tendría por
qué ser así pero lo es el caso es que
las consecuencias no se han hecho
esperar
y harley davison el popular fabricante
de motos uno de los grandes iconos de
los eeuu y todo un orgullo nacional en
palabras ojo del propio trump ha
anunciado ahora que trasladará parte de
su producción desde sus fábricas en eeuu
hacia nuevas fábricas en europa
[Música]
tenéis tiene una explicación cuando tran
castigó a la unión europea con aranceles
sobre el acero y el aluminio la unión
europea respondió con más aranceles por
ejemplo incremento del 6 al 31 por
ciento el arancel sobre las
importaciones de motos fabricadas en
estados unidos
tras el cáncer
davis y extensiones no fueron mix y
cuánto supone esto pues aproximadamente
de media unos 2.200 dólares por cada
moto un coste al que evidentemente no
tendrán que hacer frente las motos de
los fabricantes europeos como bmw y
gracias a un acuerdo comercial entre la
unión europea y japón tan poco las de
yamaha kawasaki honda es decir los
principales competidores de harley
davison
esta es una prueba más del daño de los
aranceles unilaterales la mejor manera
de ayudar a los trabajadores
estadounidenses consumidores y
fabricantes es abrir nuevos mercados
para ellos no elevar las barreras a
nuestro propio mercado
paul ryan congresista republicano por
wisconsin y presidente de la cámara de
representantes y tal y como os podéis
imaginar teniendo en cuenta el carácter
de donald trump esta noticia le hizo
ponerse furioso e incluso llegó a
amenazar por twitter claro a la propia
compañía una harley davidson nunca
debería ser construida en ningún otro
país sus empleados y clientes ya están
muy enfadados con ellos si se trasladan
atentos será el principio del fin se
rindieron renunciaron el aura se
esfumará y se les impondrán impuestos
como nunca antes un presidente de la
casa blanca' amenazando y dañando la
imagen de una gran empresa
estadounidense por el simple hecho de
tomar sus decisiones bienvenidos a la
norteamericana de trump
ahora bien una pregunta que nos podemos
hacer es necesitar realmente la mítica
compañía de motos trasladar parte de su
producción a europa atentos
necesita harley davidson mirar al mundo
amigos lo cierto es que las empresas
norteamericanas tienen ya suficientes
retos y problemas como para encima tener
que soportar las grandes ideas o
disparates que nacen en la casa blanca-
veréis la guerra comercial de donald
trump ha tenido un impacto fuerte en
empresas como harley davison por un lado
sus costes se han incrementado por los
aranceles al acero y el aluminio solo en
el caso de la empresa de motos esos
supuestos 20 millones de dólares cada
año por otro las multinacionales
norteamericanas ahora se enfrentan al
riesgo de ver cómo sus mercados se
cierran
el aumento de la producción
internacional para aliviar la carga
arancelaria de la unión europea no es la
preferencia de la empresa sino que
representa la única opción sostenible
para hacer que sus motocicletas sean
accesibles a los clientes de la unión
europea y mantener un negocio viable en
europa europa es un mercado crítico para
harley davidson declaración corporativa
de harley davidson y es que esta crisis
ha azotado a la mítica empresa de motos
en un momento ya de por sí delicado
fijaos por ejemplo en cómo ha
evolucionado su cotización en bolsa en
los últimos cuatro años
y
pero a qué se debe esta enorme caída de
más del 40 por ciento en unos años en
los que la bolsa norteamericana además
ha subido como un cohete pues
básicamente la explicación amigos está
en el cambio de época veréis hubo un día
en que este tipo de motos enormes
potentes ruidosas y fabricadas en casa
eran el sueño de muchos de casi una
mayoría de los norteamericanos
sin embargo tanto por precio son
carísimas como por el cambio de
preferencias de gustos a las
generaciones de hoy este tipo de motos
ya no les llaman tanto de hecho la edad
media de los propietarios de una harley
en eeuu supera ojo los 50 años
y eso como os podéis imaginar se traduce
perfectamente en la cifra de ventas y
beneficios tan solo en los últimos tres
años las ventas de la compañía se han
reducido un 10% y los beneficios en casi
un 40% y en 2018 las cosas van aún peor
así que como veis esta es la razón por
la que esta empresa necesita sí o sí
mirar al exterior tanto a europa como
asia y si no hay libertad comercial y
hay aranceles la producción tendrá que
marcharse a otros lugares
y es que no la decisión de harley
davison no tiene nada que ver con
política y desde luego no es ninguna
tradición se trata simple y llanamente
de la decisión económica comprensible y
lógica de una empresa que tiene que
competir algo que por cierto no le está
siendo nada pero que nada fácil y que
ahora además tiene que hacer frente a
las consecuencias de la guerra comercial
desatada por washington pero sabéis que
no es un caso aislado atentos
[Música]
las multinacionales
las políticas del presidente de eeuu
dañan a las empresas norteamericanas y
por extensión a la economía
estadounidense y desde luego cuanto más
allá lleve la guerra mayores serán las
consecuencias
de momento las multinacionales
norteamericanas algunas de las cuales
habían apoyado a trump o se habían
puesto de perfil se están poniendo muy
pero que muy nerviosas con todo este
asunto la mismísima general motors ha
dicho que si el presidente finalmente
aprueba aranceles a la importación de
vehículos algo que se están planteando
en la casa blanca las consecuencias
serían menos inversión menos empleos y
menos salarios para los trabajadores de
general motors en eeuu
y es que veréis pongamos como ejemplo el
caso de otro icono de los eeuu el ford
mustang que por supuesto está ensamblado
en eeuu es exportado desde aquí al resto
del mundo atentos
[Música]
algo más del 48 por ciento de las piezas
de los componentes del mustang proceden
de fuera de los eeuu así que si a todas
esas importaciones las castigas con
aranceles el resultado es el de un coche
más caro tanto para los consumidores
estadounidenses como para la exportación
un momento las harley davison y el ford
mustang dos de los grandes iconos de
eeuu afectados por las políticas de
trump menudo éxito
[Música]
y luego también empresas de otros países
que tienen fábricas en eeuu como por
ejemplo toyota fiat chrysler o bmw están
alertando de los peligros de esta guerra
la matriz de mercedes benz daimler
advierte que la batalla de aranceles
entre eeuu y china
impactará en sus ganancias
específicamente en la de sus sus hechos
en alabama pero ojo un detalle no se
trata ni mucho menos de algo que afecte
solamente a la industria automovilística
es algo que afecta a prácticamente todos
los sectores porque sí es verdad que
eeuu es la mayor economía del planeta
pero no lo olvidéis el 85 el 85 por
ciento del pib y la inmensa mayor parte
del crecimiento están fuera de sus
fronteras encerrarse es un mal negocio
[Música]
y levantar barreras va precisamente
contra los intereses de un país que
actualmente está en pleno empleo con un
número récord de trabajadores y con la
mayor producción industrial de su
historia sí lo sé donald trump habla
mucho de decir comercial y es verdad que
existe pero no por los motivos que el
presidente plantea veréis estados unidos
no tiene un déficit comercial porque
esté siendo robado ni mucho menos sino
porque básicamente el país tiene una
economía que consume más de lo que
produce si realmente donald trump
quieres reducir el déficit puede por
ejemplo frenar el inmenso gasto público
que tantos peligros y está causando como
ya vimos en este vídeo puede estimular
el ahorro o la inversión para que sus
empresas sean más productivas entre
otras muchas cosas pero desde luego la
guerra comercial es un mal negocio para
todos pero ahora turno para ti apoyas
esta guerra comercial déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y también
en esta encuesta si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo echarnos una mano
dándole a like y compartiéndolo con tus
amigos un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]
a youtube